all right ladies and gentlemen here's
the first story from the Washington
Times FBI whistleblower
counter-terrorism cases against alleged
right-wing extremists mostly entrapment
shock uh we all knew that it doesn't
matter that he's saying it because
people on the left don't want to hear it
won't believe it and they'll tell you
the news report is fake news anyway so
we've learned nothing and there's no new
developments thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next time
but but I mean that no look look with
all due respect to this FBI agent the
reality is that we do need this and we
need more of it and so I I really do
want to commend this agent for coming
out because we rag on the FBI a lot
because of what the department the
Washington field office has been doing
especially with Trump but Donald Trump I
think in his Hannity interview said he
said uh that a lot of the FBI agents
voted for him I think that's true I
think that there's a lot of FBI agents
who are good people but are too scared
to speak up so I can only say first and
foremost James who keeps got your back I
mean you you look at what Veritas does
for their whistleblowers they make sure
that they're not going to be left high
and dry so I would only recommend
anybody not just the FBI but anybody
that if you're witnessing illegal or
unethical you know actions at your
company or whatever within the confines
of the law blow the whistle I mean you
know I'm not a fan of just like leakers
for the sake of leaking there's and
there's been a lot of people who have
done that the past I'm like no no if
you're if you're there and dude is like
the Constitution and you're like no and
they're like we will punish you you'd be
like hey someone help like that's good
but this guy went through the official
channels and he was left high and dry
because he was fired he was kicked out
of the FBI uh compared officially
suspended officially suspended but but
of course he was also suspended because
he said he wouldn't go on a raid that
was specifically targeting January 6th
individuals and his allegations I mean
interrupt but it was because they wanted
a SWAT raid on a misdemeanor charge
exactly he was like what unreal no dude
and and what he's saying is absolutely
mind-boggling he's talking I mean not
mind-boggling to to us everyone knows
this but this is official confirmation
of them cooking the books exaggerating
the threat of domestic terrorism using
overzealous January 6th investigations
to harass conservatives and also
innocent Americans so this is a major
big bombshell he talks about how he was
specifically he himself was taken off
human trafficking and child abuse cases
to the point where he says there was
real life effects where children were
hurt because the FBI changed focuses
from investigating human traffickers and
child abusers to going after in innocent
people according to him that were just
even around Washington DC on January but
I we do have a correction a correction
and an apology this is not the the same
FBI agent this is a there's actually
there's two big stories right now this
is they say the second session came from
Kyle sarafin an FBI agent of six years
who was recently suspended by The Bureau
he was suspended but there was another
guy you see that story what's his name
was it Stephen friend friend yes 37 year
old SWAT team member that refused to go
on the SWAT rates that was that guy
that's who I'm talking about right now
right so so this Kyle seraphin is a
different FBI agent who has recently
suspended he uh he's worked in multiple
field offices in counter-terror and
conducted investigations of alleged
domestic extremism so we have two
different FBI agents who are outright
like this is unconstitutional both got
suspended I'm willing to bet there's
more but good for these men these are
this these are the heroes who are who
are look I think a lot of people get
into law enforcement for the right
reasons but the systems themselves are
fairly broken yeah so if you're if
you're like I'm Gonna Come out expose
this and that means I'm out and good
good that's what needs to happen just
just really quickly before I give it to
you guys the New York Post is reporting
that there's over 20 FBI whistleblowers
and they're talking about especially
with this friend guy he's talking about
specifically the FBI post de facto
designating a grassy area outside of the
capital as a restricted Zone when it
wasn't a restricted Zone in order of
course to prosecute innocent civilians
that were there on January 6th and this
is a huge huge mass of allegations that
I think are worth listening to and the
fact that this friend guy was fired is
absolutely a huge Miss Justice well I
think number one you know just think
about being a normal you know FBI agent
who wants to do their job and you see
what's happened to the bureau and the
justice department writ large over the
last five six years I mean how can you
not be outraged you know I mean we have
the president United States right now
um remember that speech with the red
lighting and everything and he's calling
half the country domestic terrorists and
these magro Republicans are trying to
destroy America and then two weeks later
a guy runs over again UV for being a
republican extreme right and and and
that's I mean the timing is not random
because we have an election coming up
here you know in 40 odd days and you've
got the president United States saying
that you've got the FBI raiding the
former president's house now you've got
the AG in in New York
um you know suing the president and his
kids all of this is political theater
right to try to mobilize their base
ahead of an election and I mean not just
that go all the way back to James Comey
right you want to talk about entrapment
I mean that guy went to president-elect
Donald Trump and said you know
congratulations Mr president-elect hey
did you um urinate on some Russian
hookers
um because there's this dossier and you
know look I mean this is salacious stuff
you know but I just want to share this
with for your own good for your own good
and then what did he do he walked
downstairs and he got into his his limo
and he typed up all the notes right
because he was trying to entrap the
president he wanted to see how the
president would react to it
there's no difference between that and
this
and I mean you look at the priorities of
of the FBI at this point where they're
spending more time going to school board
meetings trying to call parents is
domestic like anyone basically who
opposes this regime is a domestic
terrorist Joe Biden in that speech
basically said if you oppose me you're a
radical domestic terrorist so you know
exactly like like Tim was saying is you
end up with these cases where you have a
liberal who just runs over a kid for
being a republican but that's
intentional they the first step for them
in this process is to dehumanize right
that out group right well that that's
the path towards genocide of that list
we saw go viral right
yes uh and and also Steve friend he's
specifically also saying that FBI
domestic terrorism cases are being
opened up on innocent American citizens
who were quote nowhere near the capitol
on January 6th based on quote anonymous
tips and Facebook spying on people's
private messages so the fact that people
are getting raided the people that the
fact that people are getting swatted for
for just expressing messages that were
political is is such a nasty thing that
the FBI would be partaking in that of
course is destroying any semblance of
any form of Justice which of course they
have long since forgotten what it even
means in my opinion well they have a
problem with the FBI where they're
looking for like white supremacist
domestic extremists but the demands
outstripping the supply so you know this
is what they're left to have to do yeah
and they're talking about pressures from
higher up saying hey we need more white
supremacy cases we need more domestic
terrorism cases it's like this is this
is the allegations from the
whistleblowers exactly it's like the cop
towards the end of the month that has to
hit the ticket quota yeah you know so
he's looking for people who are speeding
well they're doing it for an election
quota they need they need that narrative
in the Press because it's the only thing
that motivates Democrats at this point
Democrats we've seen in the polls are
mostly now becoming white suburban and
making more than uh six figures yeah so
what motivates them I guess abortion so
their good friend the good friend of the
Democrats Lindsey Graham comes out with
that bill the 15-day Nationwide abortion
ban and like every Republican
collectively goes we literally just
argued states rights on that issue and
now what are you doing and why and it's
just he's holding up a sign saying vote
Democrat basically what do you think you
can expect from them if if you ask you
know any voter you look at any poll
um in any of these key Battleground
States here ahead of the midterm
election the top issues are the economy
inflation crime and the border right
it's not abortion so what what Lindsey
Graham did there is he just highlighted
the one issue that mobilizes their base
and distracts Republican candidates from
talking about the things that are
actually going to win them elections and
if you look at what the Democrats are
running on with this upcoming election
it is abortion and very interestingly
according to a lot of different sources
they spent tens of millions of dollars
propping up uh right Wingers
specifically Donald Trump right-wingers
and also local elections as well yep
yeah I mean they spent millions of
dollars in the Colorado Senate race
trying to elect uh odais upon the guy
who ended up winning the prime Mary I
mean the Schumer's uh pack spent
millions and millions of dollars to let
these folks and then they they cry every
day on television about how democracies
on the on the verge of ending in this
country but they're you know try to
elect
um you know the the right most
right-wing candidates in these
Republican primaries and how do you
square those two things of course it's
all theater at the end of the day yep
they're giving them millions of dollars
yeah and then they're saying these guys
are so horrible they're so bad here take
my money go go ahead if you want to run
against you it's it's it's absurd but
how do you and there are people that
believe it I mean come on that's
I don't I don't know what you do at that
point because if it really does come
down to an election of people who are
not even paying attention to the most
basic of news Democrats and their packs
are funding the Maga Republicans that
Democrats and Joe Biden are claiming are
the apocalypse but there are people who
are just so ignorant and don't pay
attention that they're sitting out there
being like Oh man these my Republicans
are bad why are they getting so much
attention oh we gotta we better vote
against them it's like bro they're being
you're voting for the people who are
propping them up in the first place I
think the vast majority of Voters uh
don't agree with the Democrats framing
of any of this and if you actually look
at you know who voters Trust on various
issues like restoring faith in democracy
isn't actually an issue that Democrats
lead on funny enough despite all them
talking about restoring democracy and
stopping Donald Trump from you know
subverting the election and yada yada
all this stuff you know Republicans
actually lead on issues surrounding the
election and securing the election and
all those sorts of things so it's it's
it I think it's going to fall in deaf
ears and I think the reason why they're
pushing that message so hard is they
don't have anything else to run on what
are they going to say we pass the
inflation reduction act that didn't
reduce inflation like I mean that's the
thing is their entire premise in this
election cycle you know there's about
six weeks left all they have left to do
is to try and distract voters because
every day every American field this
economy is getting worse crime is going
up the border is very clearly not secure
so so the you know when the Democrats
control the house the Senate the White
House and this is the result it's not
like they've got a record that they can
run on they have to completely distract
everybody yeah well this is what I keep
saying not everyone is going to get an
abortion you know what everyone does do
buy gas yeah and if that's not enough to
get them there's other huge factors like
the cost of food people can't afford to
eat they're literally taking out loans
and maxing out credit cards it's
unsustainable I I just
I don't understand how we're even
competitive how there's even a
competition in the polls at this point
with the economy on the verge of
imploding should you think that people
would just be like okay we're done with
this but I guess the issue is
Republicans suck so you know what are
you gonna get well a lot a lot of people
are saying third party you know younger
people too I I think of a part of the
problem is okay well what's what's you
know this group of Democrats got going
for him is basically every major news
organization on on in the country will
push whatever line that they need they
can pretty much you know the tech
companies will kick off anyone who you
know left-wing groups want gone like the
number of people who've been censored
from social media whether it's Shadow
band you know permanently if they can
ban the for the performer president of
the United States like you know they can
ban anyone they want and and you're
seeing that happen right now and the
election cycle I think yeah I think what
you're getting at there is there is sort
of like a non-response bias from a lot
of people who've just been worn out I
think from covid and lockdowns and all
of those things that they don't
participate as much in the censorship
too smug like you mentioned but I think
also and we've talked about this a
little bit on ruthless
you know when when you're talking your
average uh voter you know in the summer
or you know before Labor Day they're
busy they're traveling they're going on
vacation they're with their kids now
their kids are back in school now that
we're post Labor Day and you're starting
to see all of these polls move towards
Republicans and the reason why is
everyone's waking up and looking around
for someone to blame because they blame
Joe Biden they already blame him you
look at the right track wrong track in
the polling in this country or you look
at his approval and man he's like 37 38
approval right but they don't
necessarily associate that with their
Democratic senator or whatever but now
little by little those voters are
looking around they're saying well how
can I express that frustration with Joe
Biden oh you know what I'm going to vote
against Catherine Cortez master I'm
going to vote against Maggie Hassan
well I'm hearing people saying that the
the stream is Shadow banned and
notifications aren't going out and stuff
like that it's been a recurring theme
yeah and so I was just checking my phone
and I got I got an auto post outside of
the video stream some kind of unique
YouTube Auto post that says Can you spot
the manipulation in some weird little
cartoon and it's a video but it's like
YouTube created a special post only for
them it looks like and then it's just
like some guy watching a video and then
when you click it it's like how to fight
misinformation so we know and
interesting we know what's going on
thanks for checking out this segment
from the timcast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the timcast IRL podcast
and there's a massive library to check
out so again go to timcast.com or tune
in Monday through Friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there